let's talk about the fact that this is
barack obama's democratic party
so the battle inside the democratic
party right now between the so-called
moderates the joe manchins of the party
or even the joe bidens of the party
against the sort of alexander
ocasio-cortez squad
elizabeth warren bernie sanders wing of
the party that battle is over and the
reason that the battle is over is
because there is no
immune response to the argument that is
being made by people like ocasio-cortez
that the people like rashida talib the
people like elizabeth warren which is
that the system itself is deeply corrupt
the reason there is no immune response
is because barack obama killed the
immune response
the great lie of barack obama's tenure
is that he was a unifying president who
believed in foundational american
principles he absolutely did not
the 2012 election i think broke the
country because in 2008 barack obama was
elected
along the lines of i am here to unify
i'm here red states no blue states
united states we've had a lot of racial
conflict in this country in my own
person
i have felt that pain but now i am a
symbol of hope
right that was his whole 2008 campaign
and then come 2012
everybody who opposed him was a racist
sexist bigot homophobe
if you didn't like him it was because
you had not uncovered the bigotry in
your own heart
and in fact his agenda was about a
vision for the country that may have
moved beyond the founders okay so now he
has a memoir out
and the memoir is making pretty damned
clear where he comes from okay the
memoir is not vague
it's it's it is slightly coded
when i say it's slightly coded i mean
that he pays sometimes lip service to
what he says are american principles
that are actually not foundational
american founding principles but
barack obama is the he is the pathway
for the democratic party moving forward
that's what they think this is what the
democratic party thinks and this is why
the future of the democratic party looks
a lot more like the squad and a lot less
like joe manchin which is why you have
that
that particular tweet from aoc glaring
at your mansion right that is the future
of the democratic party it's radicals
all the way down
hey so barack obama releases a 768-page
volume one of his memoir first of all
for anybody who believes that donald
trump has narcissistic personality
disorder let me introduce you to a man
named barack obama
nobody has ever loved barack obama more
than barack obama loves barack obama
jeffrey tubin doesn't love jeffrey tube
as much as barack obama loves barack
obama
okay it is it is absurd how much barack
obama loves himself in barack obama the
man has written at this point this is
his third memoir
and volume one is longer as i have said
than the five books of moses
not kidding in the original hebrew this
is a 768-page memoir
that's volume one hey he didn't
accomplish anything when he was pr he
did obamacare and then he had a bunch of
executive orders and he undermined the
fundamental unity of the country so i
guess there was
there are a few things that he did but
is that worthy of like 1500
pages maybe he'll just continue writing
these memoirs forever
i don't know winston churchill wrote
this many memoirs and winston churchill
is actually an important human
i don't think that barack obama is a
particularly important human in the vast
panorama of american politics except for
destructive things that he has done
to the body politic okay but that
doesn't stop the media from just
drooling over in the new york times book
review
barack obama is as fine writer as they
come it is not merely this book of voids
being ponderous as might be expected
even forgiven of a hefty memoir but that
it is nearly always pleasurable to read
sentence by sentence the pro's gorgeous
in places
detail granular and vivid jeffrey tube
in writing that
right there i mean that is a lot of lot
of book review journalism
going on right there okay so what does
barack obama actually say
in his memoirs well we have an early
expert from the atlantic another place
that is basically a barack obama
stenographer jeffrey goldberg famously
was sort of the place that barack obama
would go to vomit all of his bile at his
enemies and jeffrey goldberg would just
sit there and read it and not along
in fact jeffrey goldberg was so much of
a tool of the obama administration that
ben rhodes
was a fiction writer who helped craft
the iran deal the garbage iran deal
openly stated that he used jeffrey
goldberg's as a stenographer for his
idiotic
brazilian politics anyway the atlantic
which fired kevin williamson for the sin
of being pro-life but
obviously will print nearly anything
abram kennedy writes over there
they they printed some of barack obama's
memoir here is the here is
are the paragraphs that that stick out
the most okay so
the the theme of barack obama's
presidency and his life is that he is
disappointed in you you get this from
michelle obama too he's disappointed in
you
and he's disappointed in american
democracy because what he wants from you
and from american democracy
is a radical remaking he wants a radical
re-shifting
he talks about the contest between
democrats and republicans
and of course it goes to this deeper
point that democrats have fallen head
first into
which is that if you do not believe in
the democrats radical agenda on every
score is because you're a racist sexist
bigot homophobe
this is barack obama a twice elected
president by wide margins both times
talking about how the american people
are garbage
he says this contest is not new
right right now we are seeing a crisis
rooted in a fundamental contest between
two opposing visions of what america is
and what it should be a crisis that has
left the body politic divided angry and
mistrustful
and has allowed for an ongoing breach of
institutional norms procedural
safeguards and the adherence to basic
facts both republicans and democrats
once took for granted first of all being
lectured on basic facts
by captain if you like your doctor you
can keep your doctor is a somewhat going
but barack obama says this contest is
not new of course in many ways
it has defined the american experience
it's embedded in founding documents that
could simultaneously proclaim all men
equal and yet counts a slave as
three-fifths of a man
it finds expression in our earliest
court opinions as when the chief justice
of the united states bluntly explains to
native americans that their tribe's
rights to convey property aren't
enforceable
because the court of the conqueror has
no capacity to recognize the just claims
of the conquered
it's a contest that's been fought on the
fields of gettysburg and appomattox but
also in the halls of congress
on a bridge in selma alabama across the
vineyards of california and down the
streets of new york a contest fought by
soldiers
but more often by union organizers
suffragists pullman porters student
leaders waves of immigrants and lgbtq
activists
armed with nothing more than picket
signs pamphlets or a pair of marching
shoes
at the heart of this long-running battle
is a simple question do we care to match
the reality of america
to its ideals do we really believe that
our notions of self-government and
individual freedom equality of
opportunity and equality before the law
apply to everybody or are we instead
committed in practice if not in statute
preserving those things for a privileged
few right again
if you don't believe in all the radical
policy prescriptions of barack obama
then you believe in reserving freedom
and prosperity and equality of
opportunity to a privileged few
are you a bad person not only are you a
bad person it turns out um
you might be a racist and also the
founding fathers might be a racist so he
he says i'm all in favor of founding
principles even though i might not
really believe that the founding
principles are in fact the founding
principle
right here here's where we get into the
radical 1619 project territory of barack
obama's thought he says
i recognize there are those who believe
it's time to discard the myth that an
examination of america's past
and an even cursory glance at today's
headlines show that this nation's ideals
have always been secondary to conquest
and subjugation
a racial caste system and rapacious
capitalism and that to pretend otherwise
is to be complicit in a game that was
rigged from the start
and i confess there have been times
during the course of writing my book as
i've reflected on my presidency and all
that's happened since
when i've had to ask myself whether i
was too tempered and speaking the truth
as i saw it too cautious and either word
or deed convinced as i was that by
appealing to what lincoln called the
better better angels of our nature
i stood a greater chance of leading us
in the direction of the america we've
been promised i don't know
he doesn't know you know he doesn't know
he doesn't know if these were actually
maybe the myth maybe the myth is wrong
maybe america was founded in racist
sexism bigotry homophobia
exploitation and then he says what i can
say for certain is i'm not yet ready to
abandon the possibility
of america oh so so again you guys you
just keep disappointing barack obama but
here's the thing
in order to not disappoint barack obama
what you have to do is you just have to
concede
that's what you need to do you need to
concede to all of his radical opinions
and if you don't it's because you want a
worse america you're a bad person
okay this is aoc kind of language this
is not the language of unity this is not
the language of discussion
this is not the language of a common
vision for the future this is the
language of radicalism
barack obama speaks it fluently he's
able to cover it in a way that the
radicals and the squad aren't but he's
just he's every bit as radical as they
are
he just gets it just takes him a little
bit longer to word his way around it
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content